tant d'émotions en 'tendre' faire une
annonce pour anthony kavanagh sa porte
en moi la radio j'ai porté pendant neuf
mois tu peux même portée de vie des
hôtels et des canadiens qu est ce qui m
les frères jack gold arte ou si elle
s'écrase n'importe où la ville est sans
dessus dessous
une très belle histoire
ça s'appelle comment c'est loin sortie
en juin commençait loin
deux côtés
mais je dormais
vent les chutes échoue ps de confiture
pour peugeot serait jaloux pilon youzhny
dieuze the web aig a ma gueule et la
pendule monsieur période s'il vous plaît
bonjour le quai des arts c'est pour le
daniel pennac tout ça voilà bien vous
avez votre analyse oui
je me derrière je crois mais je m'en
vais ce soir
même si le silence
tout au mieux
monsieur
ça c'est pour 2015 les bons souvenirs de
l'année dernière bienvenue en 2016 tous
nos voeux on file tout de suite à vire
au théâtre du préau où carole et
stéphanie vont nous présenter la
nouvelle compagnie qui s'installe dans
ce théâtre
alors on est en plein coeur du théâtre
du préau à vire savine et c'est la
compagnie des échappées dit que vous
allez accueillir pendant trois ans et ça
tout à fait c'est un accompagnement de
trois ans en résidence de cette
compagnie les échappées vif qui dirigé
par philippe baronnet qui est metteur en
scène et acteur concrètement quels
qu'est ce que ça va pouvoir vous
apporter à vous et à la compagnie
travailler comme ça en résidence ce
durant ces trois années
eh bien écoutez à nous ça nous apporte
de la jeunesse de la vitalité puisque
c'est une compagnie qui vient juste de
se structurer une compagnie d'acteurs
principalement et eux ça les aide à se
former à grandir et à s'implanter en
normandie réussi à dormir cette nuit
la maladie de la jeunesse ce sont des
mots qui ont été écrits en 1926 mais on
a un peu la donne un peu l'impression
qu'ils sont actuels pourtant oui
j'espère j'espère il me semble que toute
grande pièce doit avoir un côté
intemporel donc là c'est sûr ça le
contexte historique et très particulier
dans cette pièce c'est
l'entre-deux-guerres c'est au sortir
c'est à vienne en 1926 donc au sortir de
la première guerre mondiale avec un pays
qui est qui en crise avec une chute des
valeurs mais
il me semble que ce que dit bruckner à
l'intérieur de cette situation du
désarroi des jeunes gens de la violence
de la cruauté de l'humour de
l'intelligence avec laquelle ils
rebondissent je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'intemporel est-ce que ça à voir
avec moi et si tu personnes en quoi ça
me regarde c'est toi qui l'a voulu
ya que moi qui l'ait voulu est ce que tu
me veux un mercredi par mois au théâtre
de vire il y a aussi les mercredis de la
parole ça commence demain de quoi il va
être question demain soir stéphanie
alors ce mercredi la parole sabine est
organisé par un petit journal qui
s'appelle la titille euse et
concrètement le thème ce sera donc
l'esprit de charlie 1 an après qu est ce
que c est ce que c'est de la
commémoration est ce que ces nigauds
l'inauguration de grisantes m ou est ce
que c'est le combat de la liberté
d'expression tout ça vous allez pouvoir
le retrouver donc demain soir lionel le
mercredi 6 janvier à 19h au théâtre le
préau dans son espace bar et c'est
gratuit et cette soirée débat discussion
sera suivie d'une projection de films à
21h c'est le film l'humour à mort voilà
je crois qu'on a tous dit oui on a tout
dit pour laon on a tous là pour ce soir
viable
bah ouais mais pas mal oui bah écoute
moi je dis que c'est pas mal pour une
première journée de reprise doit avoir à
peu près là